i guess like moving on from like ava as
a franchise we can
we can we can like tag you back in now
corner we can tag you back in
like has there been any other like
points or like series or franchise where
you've kind of like grown up with that
franchise and and
you've had like you've seen the
franchise come back years and years
later and you it's
you view it differently as an adult as
opposed to when you saw it as a kid
because i remember the first time it
happened to me was remember when toy
story 3 got ready i was literally
thinking toy story when you said that
yeah yeah yeah i feel that's the only
thing that's like stuck around right i
think there's been two has been toy
story three and american pie reunion
right
huh what i can't relate to the ladder
unfortunately yeah i i think american
pie was like because like when american
when american pie one and two got
released it was [ __ ] massive during
not even like my generations but i think
like i really saw american pie because
it was like my older cousin's generation
they would like put it on tv and i'm
just like yo there's there's those
[ __ ] boobs on on the tv what the
[ __ ] going on here like like like this
is that i'm allowed to do this that came
out today yeah i know oh my god but
i remember i remember watching like
because that's how i experienced
american pie one and two and it was
[ __ ] massive and then seeing american
pirate union and just seeing everyone as
just like
responsible adults and just like being
adult like is that what that's about
yeah having like children like because
they they they have a high school union
and you see these characters and they're
one they're like a lot older yeah and
people have jobs and they have children
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is this what
the
what's what's that what's happened to my
childhood no no no you're like it's like
a real high school reading yeah you see
it everyone's still in uni right
everyone's seen getting still getting
pissed and partying right i'm pretty
sure i saw uh his dad she knows dad in
american pie yeah he's in every movie
yeah pretty sure i just saw him in
canada when i was on like the ski lift i
sat next to him i'm near certain i did
he spoke to me as well and he had the
exact same voice but i couldn't exactly
see his face he's wearing ski stuff he
looked like it and i was like i think
this is him
you should have just been like are you
the dad from american ice cream i wasn't
yeah yeah
well no then you could have spun it
being like you sound just like him i'm
near certain it's him but i was like 14
so i didn't want to oh right i was like
i swear he swears [ __ ] how do you
remember that [ __ ] because i literally
just reminded me and i remember getting
off the skillet thinking like
was it
the guy from here you see like this
[ __ ] bushy
of course
that's the one thing i remember
[Music]
no but like uh yeah well i mean have you
seen all the toy stories i haven't seen
toy story before good i was i was like
toy story don't toy story three was my
ava four point well yeah you know where
where where i weigh what no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no where where i watched it and i'm
just like that was a nice send-off to
yeah yeah and then they made a fourth
one yeah
don't bother watching three i didn't
really like three i didn't like it so
much i i liked i like it felt special to
me because it felt like you know i was
saying
the end of twitter toy story of toy
story 3.0
[Laughter]
yeah we're just like seeing andy grow up
and seeing
um i'm sorry yeah i mean i mean we need
like a toy story like 1.0 yeah
what is the plot toy story for why is
there anything they go about the circus
i don't even i haven't even watched
i saw toy story 4 in cinemas
because it was available i went to go
see with aki just because we were like
we want to go to the cinemas what's
playing right now oh toy story 4 is
there all right let's go watch it
because at that point i hadn't heard
anything about it so
yeah let's go
it [ __ ] sucks it really does suck i
mean the movie is decent but literally
the last 15 minutes of that movie not
only ruined the movie but just
completely ruin the entirety of the toy
story franchise yeah i heard it broke a
lot of the rules and also it kind of
like ruined woody's character yeah it
completely destroyed every character and
it just ends off with like this
well woody's on the road now also not
that invested in the cast of toy story
so if you know if buzz commits war
crimes i'm not really gonna care that
much i'm just gonna be like all right
well i mean he shouldn't have bombed
that but i mean like at least at least
toy story three right obviously not
going to spoilers but at least toy story
three you could spoil toy story theory
really i think it's okay i don't know
there might be people like i can't
believe this is not even a four-pointer
i can't believe they ruined the ending
of toy story spoiled toy story three all
right well okay well like with toy story
for three like like you know that scene
where woody's like so long partner like
that
like that was like really [ __ ] nice
like that that made me tear up a little
bit i just didn't like the fuzz bear uh
the care bear villain i just did i i was
like well i mean at least it didn't last
right yeah i guess so it didn't last i
think the scene that stuck out to me
what's with toy story three if we're
getting into spoiler territory scenario
scene yeah the incinerator oh yeah of
course oh [ __ ] what i hated that scene
what what it just dragged on and you
knew what was going to happen it was
like all right come on
all right
do you think they should have died yeah
i would have it would have been nice
famous pixar movie what a toy story just
then cut to like the factory where they
make buzz and andy it's just like it
just cuts like a pile of ashes but you
pulled like a rick and morty he's like
actually that was the alternative
universe of you know that would have
truly ruined toy story we saw like 60
000 buzzes in like toy story 2 why
couldn't we have like spanish buzz take
over you know
what's why why el buzz
i'll tell you who would have killed off
the toy story cast hidayakiano
yeah
they go into the incinerator and then
they explode in a giant cross
[Laughter]
the end the end you know [ __ ] your
childhood kids they're toys if they
weren't anywhere near an incinerator
they would have melted and been deformed
well yeah of course also what year is
this where we have incinerators attached
to like kindergartens or whatever
that is true who installed an
incinerator in a kindergarten how how
irresponsible is this why was that there
don't go anywhere with children
wait was this
in the kindergarten like completely
nearby right or something i'm pretty
sure it was nearby or something i don't
know what
why i just
didn't they didn't they go to a garbage
dump i don't [ __ ] know yeah they went
to yeah that's right
i just thought it was attached to like
the school
the kindergarten that would have been
the real plots
it was actually a disposal site all
along it was not a kindergarten i don't
know connor just [ __ ] mementoed
himself where like he just like
he you [ __ ] king crimson yourself
where like a time period just [ __ ]
disappeared you're like i guess they
just ended up and i think i'm generating
i was so bored at that point in the
movie because one and two i liked a lot
i like that a lot i love the scenery
he's like oh i gotta drive to work and
then he crosses the street yeah that
scene was a bang that's a classic that's
a glass i love that just naming off
memes now toy story one and two are
actually like really [ __ ] funny can i
just say toy story two that scene at the
airport is still one of my favorite
scenes toy story that scene that fight
fight scene can i call it a fight yeah
yeah
yeah that's that that uh that score that
that squabble scene
i felt you know a lot of the modern uh
uh i can watch a lot of the older films
that i haven't even watched before kids
ones and i thought that they're really
good because they just you know they're
as an adult you can watch them no
problem but i find that when i watch a
lot of the new uh kids films i can't i
can't watch them because they're just
oh you're talking about like recent
pixar films and stuff like that yeah i
feel like they've been like i mean this
is a common thing right whether
everyone's like oh they've been dumbed
down but i did feel that like when i
watched a lot of the older movies
like disney uh like 80s to 2000s like i
can watch any of them yeah like this is
good but i can't watch them as well i
mean like i did have like a period where
i actually sat down and like watched all
of like the recent disney movies and the
recent pixar movies because i wanted to
make sure right i was like is it
actually getting dumbed down or is that
just like my like like own opinion you
watch pinocchio that food is [ __ ] yeah
that yeah that movie is i do not
remember pinocchio have you watched
pinocchio i know i have they
cigars they turn into donkeys they smoke
cigars gamble and drink alcohol yeah
like and i'm like and these are like
these like these kids are like eight
years old i don't remember woody like
cracking open a bong like
you know what i mean
like pretty sure that's just [ __ ]
sausage party i'm pretty sure this is
actually like uh the playboy magazine
comes to life yeah this is like a
cartoon uh robot chicken uh yeah
it's like a new ground spin
i'm pretty sure this is the thing i
don't know
yeah wait don't yeah there was a robot
chicken where like they go to am i am i
dreaming this whether like they do a toy
story parody and like dildos talk or
something
i don't know
that's a million dollar idea maybe i've
made this up
that's all yours i mean that's low
hanging through but i i feel like that
sounds like a fever dream but most robot
chicken skits are adult time
with movies i can't remember what i've
made up and what is actually happening
and what has happened i shouldn't share
so much man you're giving my million
dollar ideas left and right maybe the
thing is i'll have this idea oh it's
already been done it was never done
until it wasn't i have an absolutely
abhorrent memory which is absolutely
abysmal when it comes to remembering
films and media i just can't i remember
what i remember jojo and that's pretty
much it i don't know what i felt about
the media i don't remember much about it
just like one or two scenes here and
there that's all i remember i i think
that's pretty common though
well i i think especially if you can't
remember character names either well i
think i'm i'm also shitty yeah but i
feel that's especially the case for
people who have consumed like a shitload
of media right like after a while like
your brain's gonna over cap with that
kind of [ __ ] yeah much the modern day
problem of too much too much too much
consumption too much media i can't
remember [ __ ] anything now i'm
watching youtube shorts and i feel like
my brain has like one second memory